the United States of America is made up
of 50 states you can tell by the number
of stars on our flag the country started
with only 13 rebellious colonies and
these colonies broke away from England
in 1776. from then on it has grown
steadily one state after the other
admitted to the union to get us to 50.
the latest inclusion is Hawaii which
became a state in 1959. but you know not
all proposed States throughout American
history were accepted so come along as I
tell you about the six states that never
became States the almost States of
America
foreign
this video is brought to you by my
patreon so most of y'all probably
already know what patreon is a platform
where audiences can financially support
their favorite creators online making
money online and having a sustainable
income from online content creation can
be hard so patreon allows creators Like
Yours Truly to receive direct support
from their viewers like you I've been
making educational videos on YouTube for
over two years now you see I graduated
from University in 2020 and as I'm sure
you remember that wasn't a very fun time
so I started making YouTube videos to
fill my time and keep me from going
crazy and the growth and positive
response to my channel has been really
overwhelming you may have seen me
already mention my patreon in my last
few videos and I already have two
patrons Brian and Peter I just want to
take a second to shout them out
specifically as my first patrons it
means a lot so there are three tiers on
the page Baron Earl and Duke each with
different perks available so if you want
to support me or if you want some of the
perks that come with the page you can
click the link in the description or go
to the address you see on screen right
now and if you are unable or unwilling
that's totally fine the best support I
receive from you is subscribing liking
commenting and just watching my videos
now back to our regularly scheduled
programming thanks a lot
now this video will not be about
possible 50 First Dates so DC Puerto
Rico or any other current territories
won't be discussed this video is also
not about current secession plans or
plans to break up States so the states
of Lincoln and Jefferson won't be
discussed either because they have
current support and lastly there have
been dozens of possible States
throughout American history if I try to
go over all of them this video would be
too long so these are my six favorite
ones
let's go chronologically starting before
the United States even became the United
States with charlotteina
in the 1750s as in most other periods of
History the English and French were at
War
in Europe they called this conflict the
Seven Years War but here in North
America it is remembered as the French
and Indian War while we won't go into
the specifics here but long story short
the English one as a consequence all of
France's North American territory was
ceded to England and Spain
this area below the great lakes and
above the Ohio River became known as the
Northwest Territory
some Brits thought it would be best to
settle the area to keep the French out
and intimidate the local native peoples
they suggested sending British and
especially Irish prisoners to the area
to colonize it charlatina had some
support but in the end all King Georgie
rejected the plan he issued the Royal
Proclamation of 1763 barring American
colonists from settling west of the
Appalachians
next up we have Transylvania no not that
Transylvania
no no no this one in Kentucky or where
Kentucky will be
it may seem kind of strange that these
places have the same name but Sylvania
simply means wooded area so Transylvania
means through the woods this area right
here was owned by the Cherokee Indians
the Transylvania company bought the land
in 1775. Daniel Boone a land surveyor
was hired by the company to survey and
settle the land so he and his party set
up a town on the Kentucky River called
Boonsboro which was to be the capital of
a new colony called Transylvania
the new Transylvania government sent a
representative to the Continental
Congress that year but their bid to
become their own territory was rejected
especially by Virginia and North
Carolina who already had claims on that
land
and in 1778 the Virginia General
Assembly declared the Transylvania
Colony illegal the land eventually
became part of Kentucky in 1792
next up we have Franklin
so after the Revolutionary War the newly
formed United States was in debt to help
North Carolina voted to give their
territory west of the Appalachians to
Congress
while the jester was appreciated the
Congress had little interest in the land
probably because it was difficult to
administer
the Frontiers men who lived in the area
who didn't feel well represented by
North Carolina anyway thought this would
be a good time to petition Congress for
Statehood this actually made sense as
the area because of its geographic
isolation was basically self-governing
anyway
the petition almost passed with seven
states voting in favor but this wasn't
the two-thirds majority needed to admit
a new state so the idea failed the
residents of Franklin convened to
discuss their options they decided to
contact their namesake Benjamin Franklin
who remember was still very much alive
he sent a polite letter back but offered
no support
not to be deterred the franconians
franklonians
franklinites
the Franklin Knights decided rather than
become a part of North Carolina again to
declare independence this didn't last
too long as running an independent
country in the wild west with European
Empires and American Indians to worry
about proved difficult
when they tried to join the Spanish
Empire in 1788 no really they tried to
do that the North Carolina militia
marched in arrested the governor and
took control of the territory
the area that would have become Franklin
eventually became part of Tennessee
next we have edelsvarine in the 1840s
the German Confederation was in
financial trouble so a group of 21
noblemen gathered in the castle of one
Adolf the Duke of Nassau who would later
become Grand Duke of Luxembourg they
hashed out a plan to start a new German
land somewhere in the American West they
decided on Texas which at this point was
an independent republic
these German Nobles purchased this land
from the Republic of Texas
but while the area was claimed by Texas
it was really controlled at least mostly
by the Comanche Indians the Comanche
were known to be uh not super welcoming
to Europeans and were a pretty hardcore
about it surprisingly though they seemed
to get on pretty well with the Germans
adel's Vereen and the penateka Comanche
signed a treaty that seemed to have been
followed by both parties
German immigration to edel's varying
ended in 1853 due to the large amount of
debt the adults varying Society was
under
turns out transporting large amounts of
Germans across the Atlantic was more
expensive than they had thought
and in the aftermath of the
Mexican-American War Texas became part
of the Union so the dream of a German
state in the Heart of Texas ended
next we have the state of Deseret in the
1820s in New York a young man named
Joseph Smith was allegedly visited by
the angel Moroni and shown a set of
Golden Plates
on these plates were written a story a
story of ancient Israelites sailing to
the Americas and of Jesus visiting them
after his crucifixion this new religious
movement was of course called Mormonism
Joseph Smith's ideas attracted many
followers and detractors alike
and due to this religious persecution
the Mormons decided to move west
but then in 1844 Joseph Smith was killed
by an angry mob and the leadership of
the Mormon Church past to Brigham Young
Brigham Young decided to move the
Mormons even further west to the Salt
Lake City basin
when they got there young claimed a very
large tract of land that included
current day Nevada Utah Arizona and much
of Southern California
this area was not actually controlled by
the United States at the time it was
instead controlled by Mexico but again
after the Mexican-American War the
territory became American
so Brigham Young went to Congress and
petitioned for the Mormon land of
Deseret to become a state
but the American Congress and the
American people didn't much like or
trust the Mormons
and they especially didn't approve the
polygamy that the Mormons practiced
because of this the proposal was
rejected later in the 1890s the Mormons
stopped practicing polygamy or at least
stopped practicing it openly this change
was enough for the U.S Congress to agree
to make the Mormon territory a state of
course they made it smaller and they
rejected the name Deseret a name found
in the Book of Mormon instead going with
Utah named for the Ute Indian tribe
lastly we have Tex Lahoma and by the
name I know you know where it is in the
early 20th century there was a new toy
that was all the raid the automobile
these automobiles needed roads to be
useful and so local governments started
building these roads but rural areas
like for instance Oklahoma and Northern
Texas were left out the governments were
spending their time and money building
roads in cities and more populated areas
so some of the citizens of this area
decided they ought to make their own
state by the 1930s the plan was pretty
popular even amongst politicians
AP cites the de facto leader of the text
Lahoma movement claimed that 65 percent
of politicians agreed with his plan
though we don't really know where he got
these numbers one of these was John
Nance Garner the vice president at the
time though he was known for supporting
strange initiatives
the plan never went through of course
partly due to the fact that Texans even
ones ignored by the representatives
still like being Texans
so here are the six almost States of
America well the sixth that I talked
about there are others and maybe I'll do
another video talking about them in the
future but for now thank you so much for
watching if you want to support the
channel my patreon is in the description
and if not please like And subscribe bye
foreign